crazy uh talk about like um one how did
you for people who don't know I mean
you've sold the story a lot but just
what's like a quick synopsis on how you
got like your past and how you got uh
initially started in um into the real
estate game so my story is not a
traditional real estate story right or a
real estate investor story so
uh I barely have a high school diploma
yeah right uh my parents I don't come
for money nobody in my family owned any
real estate so when I graduated high
school instead of going to college like
my friends did I chose the streets right
so everybody told me if you don't change
your life you're gonna end up in prison
and then a lesson I ended up in prison
so but at that point I turned a negative
into a positive so when I was in prison
there was a guy uh his name is Renee
which he's to this day he's my big
brother yeah he was a big real estate
developer in Hoboken New Jersey yep uh
he was one of the first guys that
invested in Hoboken when Hoboken was
Urban and then you know of course Hulk
Vulcan is probably one of the most
expensive places in New Jersey yeah so
he went in uh he had a charge for
political corruption he's never been in
prison before I caught him how to bid
and he taught me about real estate when
you say bid what is it that's all about
you know to kind of talk him how
everything worked in prison right just
kind of the politics yeah the politics
the right thing to do you know don't cut
nobody on the phone don't don't cut
nobody on the child line right you know
uh don't sit here don't say you know
stuff like that watch TV in this team
you were like his big homie in jails
yeah yeah yeah even though like
yeah yeah so
um what was your first like do you
remember your first property was it a
successful one so when I get out of jail
which is crazy this was the wild cowboy
days back in
2006 right so it's right but this before
the crash happened so right which is
people always ask me that I can't
believe this so right out the half uh
out of prison I go to the halfway house
and I start doing mortgages wow so here
I am in the halfway house and I have
access to people's information I just
came out of prison right but those were
the wild cowboy days right yeah so I I
come home I started doing mortgages you
know it was crazy back then in that
market I remember my first loan that I
did the lady was 80 years old she bought
a house for 480 000 and we got her 100
financing
what the [ __ ] if she was that such a
great way like I said crazy everybody
was getting approved for houses but back
then if you bought a house right I will
buy a house because you bought a house
to compete with you and I would get
approved like the next day there's no
problem yeah you buy a house today and
it's worth fifty thousand dollars more
the next day and you can you go and cash
out and get a lot of credit that's crazy
it was crazy back there right that's why
the bubble happened so I came home I
started doing mortgages was doing great
you know straight out of prison I'm
making 15 20 000 a month right which is
awesome then Market collapses
my wife's Cube and I'm Dominican so we
opened up a Cuban restaurant we had no
business opening up a restaurant right
we don't know nothing about the
restaurant tough business tough business
my mother-in-law uh she's a chef so we
opened up the restaurant and you know we
were kind of counting our heart right
right so
first two months we're doing great right
the next thing you know man we just it
was we got into the restaurant business
that's when there was like a shortage
right of everything I think it was like
e for shortage or something like that so
rice went up flower went up everything
everything went up right a back a box of
plantings went from like 20 to like
ninety dollars right Jesus so
we're in the restaurant for like a year
and a half we lost everything we I came
home doing great with mortgages switched
to this right losing everything again we
had uh two houses and foreclosure that
we owned at the time and um I saw an
opportunity in real estate I took it
and I made 70 000 and we closed the
restaurant the next day what were the
details on the that first seventy
thousand that was a three family home in
Paterson New Jersey okay yeah and I I
did that as a flip
so you bought it fixed it up flipped it
yep so I I actually bought it uh and the
market was still at that point not going
down all the way so it was still like
right there so I bought it and I sold it
to somebody else and made a quick
seventy thousand wow yep that's crazy
how did you did you what was your
financing process for that first house
well uh the person that bought it off of
me they bought the cash
and I got it I got that house if I
remember correctly uh I believe it was
FHA